wenn es um den schutz unserer
bevölkerung geht wir sind bereit ob im
inland oder im ausland zu lande zu
wasser und aus der luft
militär war für mich schon aufgrund
familiärer hintergründe das größte für
mich und somit als von einem weg gegeben
der mich in dieser verband geführt ward
eingerückt f kurs gemacht und
grundsätzlich einmal die normale
militärische laufbahn durchgemacht bis
zum unteroffizier und dann für das ja
komm anderen kriegen
du magst nicht die ausbildung fertig und
bis dann darüber drüber soldat oder ein
ständiger laufender prozess sich
immerfort bilden fit zu halten
fähigkeiten erhalten es dauert bis man
wirklich dann mit sich selbst zufrieden
ist
wir sind zum schutz der bevölkerung dar
ob im inland oder im ausland
das ist einer der kernaufgaben des
jagdkommandos die speerspitze sozusagen
das sind das erst dadurch schützt mal
nach österreich
mein leben ist das abkommen das auch an
oberster stelle steht und so lange ich
operativ tätig bin ist dass der
lebensmittelpunkt